now it's time to do some job searching
our last video set up companies and jobs
using the Google cloud talent solution
job search API
let's search against the API and see
what comes up there's a few things we
should include in the request when
searching for jobs so let's cover those
and then run some searches for every
search we need to provide request
metadata this is an object that provides
information about the user making the
search request it's important to provide
these details to ensure a consistent
user experience as well as to better
train the machine learning models first
three properties and the object are
required domain should be the domain
where the search is hosted from such as
food comm session ID and user ID our
value specific to the user doing the
search and should properly be obfuscated
before being provided such as hashing
them that way the API doesn't see any
personally identifiable information but
it can tell when it's the same session
and user device info is optional and
consists of the ID and type of device so
you can distinguish between a web search
and an app search for example allow
missing IDs is a boolean that makes
those first three fields optional when
the API is fully implemented you should
always aim to provide all of the
requested information to ensure the best
results you can use allow missing IDs if
you can't get all the information or if
you're testing for our sample code will
provide some static values for these
technically that's the only required
field for doing a search but then the
request will come back with all sorts of
jobs more than likely we'll want to
actually search for something so we'll
include a job query the job query can be
pretty simple with a query string for
the actual search terms and different
filters to help narrow down the jobs
that get returned for instance you can
return only jobs from a specific company
or filter by employment types we'll just
stick to the query string for now but
there's more information about filters
in the description below you can also
specify a job view property which is an
enum that declares how much information
you want to get back with your job
search request job view full gives you
back all the information about each job
result but you might want to save some
bytes and choose another option that
returns less
Fields pick the option that makes the
most sense for the platform you're
working on since you may get a lot of
results the API will also paginate so
you can work with the pagination
interface we recommend keeping the page
size to 20 or less to avoid latency
issues and always use pagination through
the API rather than trying to load in
all the results you'll get a next page
token in the response so if there's more
jobs you can pass it into the next
search queries page token there's also a
search mode option that lets you choose
between a normal search and a featured
job search if you want to hear more
about featured jobs check out the
previous video in this series that
explains the difference and when you
should use featured jobs there's some
other optional fields you can read about
more in the documentation but let's see
some code and run a search here's a
sample script that takes a search string
and then runs a search query will set up
the API at the top and then we call our
function here's where we set that
request metadata and grab the search
query string as I said before the
request metadata should include as much
information as possible but will still
hash the user in session information to
avoid any personally identifiable
information here we build the request
object with our search term and our
request metadata
we're also explicitly calling out that
this is a normal job search instead of a
feature job search and saying we want
the full information for each job
returned we've also got a page size for
24 now though we'd have to use page
tokens or an offset if we wanted to get
to the next page with that we'll make
the call with jobs search and we'll pass
in our object since we use job view full
we'll get a lot of details back but the
code is only going to look for two
things the title and the search text
snippet each result will return the
fields that your job view specifies and
that may be getting back a job object
for each result as well as the fields
that are specific to the results such as
the snippet now if we run the code and
we search for engineer we'll get some
results in the matching jobs field by
default these are ordered from relevance
by the ML models you can specify the
order in the search request if you need
to do some custom logic but we recommend
using the default relevance this is a
great starting point for getting data
loaded into the system and
some actual searches to see what kind of
results you get looking at the raw
search response you'll see some
important additional information total
size and estimated total size can help
you with pagination and matching jobs
contain the actual search results in the
metadata section you'll also get a
request ID that's unique to this
specific search these are globally
unique IDs generated for that specific
request so if you're seeing an issue or
have a question these request IDs can be
very helpful if you need to contact
support from here you should be able to
load information into the job search API
and start doing searches in our next
video I'll talk more about the specifics
of relevance and ranking for the job
search results thanks for watching and
remember when looking for talent it's
okay to keep your head in the cloud
[Music]